si siente dolor en la parte inferior de
la espalda causado por un disco
gravemente dañado su proveedor de
atención médica puede recomendarle una
sustitución de disco lumbar la columna
lumbar está formada por 5 huesos cada
uno de ellos se llama vértebra estas
vértebras protegen la médula espinal
inferior
entre cada vértebra hay un cojín blando
de tejido llamado disco intervertebral
los discos sanos brindan suficiente
altura entre las vértebras para permitir
que la parte inferior de la espalda se
doble y absorba presión a medida que
envejece los discos pueden secarse
hincharse y volverse menos flexibles un
disco hinchado puede presionar contra
los nervios espinales la presión sobre
los nervios espinales puede causar dolor
en la espalda y las piernas a medida que
el disco empeora se pueden formar
pequeños bultos llamados espolones óseos
en las vértebras que están encima y
debajo de él los espolones óseos también
pueden comprimir los nervios espinales
esto puede hacer que las piernas se
sientan débiles y entumecidas para
comenzar el procedimiento se realiza una
incisión en el abdomen después de
alcanzar la columna lumbar el cirujano
extrae el disco gastado
luego el cirujano raspa el tejido de las
vértebras de arriba y de abajo para
dejar el hueso expuesto
a continuación se inserta el disco
artificial y se conecta el hueso
al final del procedimiento la incisión
de la piel se cierra con su duras o
pegamento quirúrgico
después del procedimiento es posible que
tenga menos dolor de espalda y que pueda
mover la espalda más fácilmente
para obtener más información sobre la
sustitución de disco lumbar hable con su
proveedor de atención médica